the established county lines business
model is to get young people to act as
mules taking drugs often on trains from
big cities to more rural areas but how
does that work in lockdown the answer
dress children as key workers use hire
cars rather than trains create deal
areas in hospital or supermarket car
parks where people are still gathering
we've heard from several sources that
this is how the business has adapted if
they were being transported using trains
if they were in public spaces then they
are definitely more visible and that's
why we've seen exploiters actually
dressing children up using outfits that
are for key workers in order for them to
pass without being noticed
but Scotland Yard revealed today that a
25 million pound home office led drive
to tackle this drugs trafficking for
Noren has dented the business this raid
today on a line running from London to
Kent in Hampshire is part of the biggest
ever coordinated drive by UK police
forces to disrupt what is estimated to
be between eight hundred and a thousand
active lines across the country as a
result in the last six months
eighty-seven County lines have been
taken out that's around 10 percent of
all active lines across 11 police forces
183 people have been charged with drug
trafficking arrests have been up 50
percent in lockdown compared with the
same time period last year during the
period of lockdown we've used it as an
opportunity to really target our drug
dealers who are dealing in county lines
we have seen them change some of the
ways that they are doing that
so he's seen a movement away from public
transport with the restrictions around
movement and perhaps more into cars
which provides more opportunities for us
police say fewer children have been
reported missing but whilst vulnerable
children are no longer in school and
less visible to social workers
children's charities still worry they've
been out of sight for long periods home
stress from lockdown and mental health
challenges could all drive them into the
wrong hands
Jason Farrell Sky News